I've never seen you this upside but I
cannot even understand their voices crap
yes because I cannot even understand
that someone with my entire life I've
been treated quite bad I should also say
like this is a warning and my English is
not that good and I just I feel I feel
really alone and I felt like I was gonna
search YouTube for people with the same
issue as me and that is being really
unattractive and I've been having lots
of issues with that because every video
I come across is with a really
attractive or normal person and they
have no idea how how it really is I was
around 13 when I got my first serious
friends they were I was 13 12 to 13 and
they were like 16 to 18 beautiful alpha
males and like they were the first ones
to start calling me ugly and that was
quite a shady neighborhood so it's like
and they were with my they were with me
cuz my mom gave them cigarettes and
stuff so they were like my guardian
sorta and they were the first people to
call me ugly
my man's from a tough country yeah
listen my bad
God blesses God bless his heart they
were friends with me because my mom gave
him that is trailer-trash nauseous
Eastern Bloc
there's not trailer-trash it all got
trailers out there it's a different life
yeah that's just the Eastern Bloc I
could see a couple of countries where
that's a reality interesting I when I
was 15 I realized that I wanted to have
love in my life I was I was 15 years
when I realized I wanted that and like
the amount of people that rejected me is
astonishing it's there's unexplainable
it's not astonishing people base himself
on looks there's a story I told you like
have you ever seen a girl say to a guy
in the bar ill that's that kind of guy
I've seen that habit I've paid so many
drinks to so many guys like that I was
just trying to get some and that's fair
everybody wants some maybe it's not
astonishing to you but the people who
don't know there's the reality exists
yeah probably is astonishing yeah I know
it does I've dealt with the first hand
like when he was talking about not being
desired at all in early school that's me
ELISA I didn't get sometimes 18 and what
I did very awkward circumstances but I
had nobody paying me no mind and I'm a
decent looking guy today but trust me I
was hella dusty most my life yeah and I
mean extra dusty I see the picture yes
very dusty so I may not be on his level
the same way he may not be on other
people's level but I do understand it
we're not in different categories we're
just in different degrees beautiful
people are in a different category yeah
absolutely even I was in that category
because there was a point that what it
was not cool being black sure but not
been having a girl yeah yeah but I'm
even talking about before that there was
some point that it was not cool being
black know I'm pushing 40 bro when I was
in elementary school it was not cool
being black let alone being Haitian hmm
so there was all types of evil I'm not
even talking I'm talking about pre my
girl oh my girl hmm just when you just
start to interact with girls and stuff
like that it was not that cool right so
yeah what he's talking about I couldn't
relate to what people were not chasing
me and I was worried there's something
wrong with me yeah thing that was wrong
with me as I was black hmm I'm not
saying there's something wrong with
being with that but at the time hmm that
was not the standard hmm I think the
total sum from when I was 15 to 17
was well over four five hundred girls
that I wrote with that I tried to get
into a relationship with well I think
that back that's astonishing that's a
lot of attempts a lot of women that's a
lot of people I don't even think I rose
people my life Scott must have been
walking was just stopping everyone he
saw that's a lot of women to probe to
brother laughing but when you're
desperate maybe he's like messaging him
online as well so he's going that that's
still a lot less options that you have
you just trying to shoot your shot rough
I understand that I've done that this is
a lot in at that age especially when
your egos that fragile to be that
persistent you took a lot of elf that's
all you say to l equals a win
I'm sitting about 2,000 so I set up like
I tried to write with told with girls
and I wrote with girls that were
overweight that didn't look so good some
of them had a big nose like me some had
big lips so this guy was doing it all
online okay so that makes a little more
sense I think he was messaging a whole
bunch of people online trying everything
so I mean online you're gonna take a lot
more losses than you will in person
that's a fact he wasn't approaching
people in person he was writing them
online which already is the one of the
worst ways you can approach people if
you're unattractive and you ugly trust
me me my online game is okay all right
in person I do way better online game is
okay meaning if I was to approach a girl
online my odds of success are way lower
than if I was to do it in person best
effect okay
online you're looking at pictures that's
all you got first off men are not good
at taking pictures No compared to women
women got that [ __ ] dumped and go look
at men's Instagram women's Instagram
night and day all right
second thing is that's all they have to
go off if you are a man there are other
qualities that they will find endearing
whether it's your skill yeah whether
it's your charm
whether it's your ability to carry
conversations in person online
conversations are there different it's
hard to really get a personality across
man so him having this lack of success
is going to be not
surprising to me because he's using the
medium that is least conducive to his
success right right some had shorter
hair I even wrote with about I think it
was like free free girls that were
handicapped this man really just said
even the wheel chair said nah I'm like
yo girl let me roll you around this
block she's like now let me get a cute
funny
listen it's not surprising because
here's the truth ugly dude should not be
involved in the online game it's like a
5-2 athlete trying to get into the NBA
bro you got better chances out of love
other sports the NBA is not for you it's
not so go to a sport where height is not
a problem and you can you really
showcase your athletic strengths let me
tell you this if you're ugly go out
there and every single one called me
ugly every single one and after two
years I gave up I gave up totally and
when I gave up I started to care more
about writing with people who had it
difficult or sad and like or didn't have
it easy and that's when I first met the
first girl in my life that wanted to be
with me and I spent seven years with
that girl and I regret it very much I
respect him even in his desperate state
he's like man I should have dumped them
here's two things one he was doing this
when he was 15 to 17 let me tell you
that is the worst time as a man to be
approaching people if you're
unattractive trust me my most of my
elves are happen in my early adult life
it is the most difficult time to
approach and try to meet people and it
will scar you forever because one your
personalities
not that well developed yet so if you
your you're probably not charming you're
gonna learn those skills later on as you
grow older you have no money you have no
equity women are only looking at looks
and popularity most people will tell you
like a lot of people are late bloomers
right they're terrible pre highschool
pre-university and then afterwards it
gets better and the reason for being is
like you come into your own you start to
bring other things to the table other
than your looks and your partner's start
to look for things in their partners
other than their looks so or not
necessarily other than but they won't be
the only priority that they're looking
at does that make sense
writing with people who had it difficult
or sad and like I didn't have it easy
what he's doing afterwards is that he's
surrounding himself with people who are
probably in a toxic mind state who are
suffering from the same problems and so
it becomes a perpetual single where you
only hear negative feedback from people
who suffer like you spiraling down right
if you're an addict and you're
recovering and you spend time with
addicts you're more likely to relapse
it's the reality of these things so your
circle will affect the way that your
mindset progresses that was a girl that
treated me so badly and was just using
me she did every she called me ugly she
forced me to walk five to ten meters
behind her she'd never hold my hand she
never kissed me
all right no let me take a second okay
all right this is what happens when a
bad person with low self-esteem meet
somebody with lower self-esteem what she
did is bad the fact that he accepted it
is worse but he accepted it because the
self-esteem was that low that he thought
that this is what he deserved in a weird
way seven years I mean listen when your
self-esteem is there it's not surprising
because people who stay with partners
who beat them every day yeah and they
die with those partners yeah so it's all
about how you view something what you
think you deserve how you value yourself
exactly yes she never did anything to
show appreciation of me she just simply
used me and it was not a good
relationship she never cared about me
she was always angry aggressive and for
the first hole fear she didn't really
want to be in an actual relationship
with me she just wanted to be with me we
had sex and we had fun I guess I'm glad
he at least got something out of it I
was worried to say I had to stand by the
bed while she banged somebody else out
of it like all right listen idubbbz calm
down but here's what does make me
optimistic this man is very
self-reflective and he's able to speak
on his past relationships honestly and
candidly and see it for what they were
which tells me that he's really been
able to move past it and that gives me
optimism sometimes you hear people
reflect on past relationships that were
terrible and they speak about it with
fondness and that's always a red flag to
me because I'm like oh you're gonna fall
into that again you know out of you're
bad at it no exactly so that's what
keeps me optimistic about his outlook
even though this is a sad story or for
3-4 years then I moved and she didn't
move with me she was like it's not worth
it if you move it's over so
it was over then she started calling me
and being like you should take me back
because you are unlovable
I remember those words so clearly you
are unlovable I take back what I said
earlier this is what happens when a
truly terrible and despicable person
with low self-esteem meet somebody with
lower self-esteem unlovable you don't
even know what love is for you to utter
those words you are incapable of such
emotion what my favorite go ahead what
rate you there are two things I'm
thinking right now one is that I thought
I I would understand a lot of this guy's
experiences because of my being raised
in my issues with self-esteem and how
I've always looked now because this is
so outlandish to both of us maybe we
don't understand no we don't and maybe
we're in a different category maybe we
didn't realize it we're in the mid
categories or maybe is that maybe he
just latched on to a really bad apple
cuz I know attractive people who've been
with why have you laughs that that is my
thing
I know attractive people who date
someone who does things to them that I
think is completely outlandish so I
don't think it's necessarily about him
being that unattractive and this happens
to ugly people I think this is just a
low self-esteem thing which can be it's
much more prolific people who are ugly
but I honestly believe I'm just
free-balling here cuz this is crazy to
me but again I think I see attractive
people with relationships that are crazy
as well the reality is that if you are
more attractive the odds of you having
higher self-esteem are probably raised
due to the fact that you're probably
gonna receive more positive feedback
because our self-esteem to some degree
is informed by how our community views
us and if you're ugly and you're
constantly getting reinforcement from
people that like yo you're terrible blah
blah blah get away from me you're
unlovable you're much more likely to
have lower self-esteem whereas a pretty
person receiving positive reinforcement
all the time is more likely to have
higher self-esteem yeah I would assume
that's the worst thing I ever felt and I
was like screw this that's the first
time I started writing again with New
Year's it it had been three years or
almost four I had lost weight I had
started exercising more I was a bit
stronger things were a little bit easier
and I started writing with new people in
my area I managed to find a girl there
by that time I met her we were just
friends it was chill
she was actually a terrible human being
[Laughter]
[Music]
the way he candidly said that no
hesitation I like this guy he's good
he's funny here we go sorta got really
annoyed of being alone and my ex wanted
to come and visit me the girl I was with
for all those years that treated me so
bad and I was so weak so I said okay and
I spent another free or it was about
four years I've spent seven in total we
first so it was about three more years
with her and those here sort of improved
quite a lot there were a lot better than
the first four years so it wasn't that
bad you wanna know I was better cuz your
self-esteem was better and what you were
willing to tolerate was probably better
because you had some hope and you
probably were a little bit more student
who you were when it comes to
relationships what I do
if you set your boundaries accordingly
people tend to respect him and that
doesn't mean just telling people which
you want except that means that when
they cross those boundaries there are
repercussions not in the sense that
you're gonna hit them but you will leave
they need to understand that there are
things that you will not accept in order
for this relation to work that's it but
it didn't work out because I was so
unhappy I was extremely unhappy I felt
like we had nothing in common she was
always angry moping complaining and she
didn't feel good and I didn't feel good
we were just tearing each other down I
couldn't forget all all the things in
the past and like we had nothing in
common except just being angry on each
other so we broke up
and with that was about five months ago
now and I move past everything quite
easily didn't I tell you that earlier
that this man moved on last five months
he was impressive for a seven-year
relationship the Batman he Polly moved
on well into the three-year period he'd
already moved past that he just hadn't
broken up yet yeah it was just you two I
can tell you a few things that I've been
through I've met people that are
extremely had girls that are extremely
overweight and don't look well as well
as well and they tell me you're not my
type you're way too ugly or them they
make up an excuse you know this is like
you know this is like I think what he's
describing is like when a homeless
person goes up to another homeless
person like hey can I sit beside you and
like it'll get away from you you're
homeless and what you're like that's how
he views it the problem is the homeless
person he approach does not think that
they're homeless like him now I'm not
that type of homeless
I'm just trying to explain the
perspective of the other person when
they're saying that kind of stuff
because people can be overweight and you
can view them as on your level doesn't
mean that they view themselves that way
because your attractiveness level to
yourself is based off how you view
yourself you think they're ugly does
that ask you me I'm fat not ugly yeah
thank you yeah I'm not saying you're
wrong I'm just saying that's how they
view themselves which makes your
perspective in regards to you being
treated unfairly
wrong does that make sense because
you're expecting us a response from them
based off what you perceive about them
right the problem is they don't perceive
themselves the way you perceive them
yeah and they're justified in that so
for you to be mad or upset about their
response as a result to me is a little
strange because the same way I'm not
entitled to tell you how you should
perceive yourself you're not entitled to
tell others how they should perceive
themselves when you approach them makes
sense makes perfect sense and then there
was this time when I had a date with a
girl and I had spent lots of money on
making a perfect day together like I had
setup everything perfectly and I went on
the subway over an hour and I stood on
the train here on the train station and
I looked for her for two hours before I
was like okay she gave up I knew it I
know a man I knew that stood up and then
I went home and she wrote that when she
saw me I was so ugly she didn't have the
encouragement to talk to me I haven't
been able to live a normal life because
my friends were commenting on me not
looking good my family's been commenting
on it everyone's always pointing it out
and I get so frustrated you need better
friends you need better friends I don't
know what else to tell you listen I have
friends who are ugly one thing I do not
tell them is that they're ugly
I don't reinforce that I don't say that
kind of stuff for people to constantly
say that to you casually as if it's okay
that says a lot about them that's that's
an ugly comment to make I would not
think listen maybe it's just my
environment I don't know what it is but
those kind of comments would never fly
so the idea that all these people are
saying this and it's a result of you
being ugly know all these people are
saying this because the people that are
surrounding you aren't the best people
same goes for your family family is rare
all right they're constantly putting
down yourself esteem all the time that's
not a good sign
and it should be something you look into
in terms of leaving that area if you
have to you know it's not because
everyone around you puts their hands on
you or beat you up that people like that
everywhere or it's because of your race
or whatever no it could just be that
your environment your immediate
surroundings are just bad it's toxic
you know when you meet one friend who's
bad and then you meet friends through
that friend there's more likelihood of
that friend having bad friends is very
high but trust me there are better
people out there for you it's like
tinder but it's called Patou it's like
tinder pretty much where I automatically
love every person no matter who it's
like a special algorithm for a program
that I made so that I click a button and
it likes 600 people every day which was
double limit and it's I've done that for
over ten days so that's I know easily
it's over 6,000 people that I have liked
on that side like like and wants to
write with and I just want to make a
note what he said about the six hundred
likes today I know he's done that I'm
like when I use tinder tinder originally
they don't know when I use tender
originally I had this thing called the
tinder Auto licker bro tinder and it's
back in the day because fire flame
flamethrower yoga flame thousand Street
Fighter nice hot scorching all day all
day bro listen I would hit one but it
was just like I would clear out the city
within three days three days I would
clear on it be like there's no one left
to like yeah you know what that's like
in a major city there's no one left to
like and then I would have this ability
to change my location so if I knew I was
going somewhere I was like boom so when
I would travel up like a girl you know
I'm saying just have a place to stay
when I when you broke and you want to
travel
tinder auto lacquer beast but it exists
no more no they find ways to cap
everything it's no longer the app it
used to be it's pretty much trash I
haven't used tinder like three years ago
I have the fact that he has no see
says with it I could definitely see that
hurting but again it's like I said
earlier like I have an extremely hard
time with online dating it's really as
difficult for me so I imagine you who's
probably lower on the scale by your own
standards and then you're gonna have a
harder time - I'm just saying online
dating is not built for men who are
below average that doesn't mean that you
can't find women or that you can't get
like you talked about the girl that you
met in your city great you would be able
to meet more women like that or better
if you were talking to them in person or
you're engaging in social activities
that enable you to meet other people
I'll give you an example
I've salsa dance okay now I don't meet
women through salsa dancing it's not my
thing
but I know a lot of ugly dudes who do
and I mean terrible looking dudes but
the fact that they've built up a skill
and they know how to talk to women ask
them to dance and showcase their skill
it makes them endearing to women I'm not
saying that you necessarily have to do
that but there are activities that you
can engage in and get good at that will
make you more endearing to the opposite
sex you think that happiness right means
that he build things to be able to date
but he didn't build himself yes I agree
with that you know what I mean like he
build algorithms I'm gonna hit more
people I'm gonna yo you have to what
works for ugly people for ugly man
whatever it's it's to better yourself I
didn't like what you were saying with
the salsa dancing somewhere that you
have to acquire more skill sets if you
just change algorithm change - I'm gonna
date change younger I go with more
people to date with more people increase
the number but you don't add value to
who you are it's not it's not gonna do
anything you're gonna be the same person
you're just gonna shoot more shots here
there's evidence of that and his own
story because initially when he was with
his girl it was terrible yeah and then
when he built a little bit more
self-esteem and built some distance it
did improve that was him raising his own
profile yeah so he changed the way
things went a little bit better sad when
people look away they are like no we
don't want to get like you as my friend
like and I'm I'm currently in a
situation where I'm waiting for plastic
surgery because that's the only way and
I'm telling you this right now
if you're unattractive the only way for
you to get a normal life is to work earn
money or go to the hospital get psycho
psych psychiatric help and if it's a
weird severe enough they will give you
free surgery or whatever your plastic
surgery can only make you marginally
better looking it can't make you
substantially fix you right so you're
gonna come out of this thinking it's
gonna fix your problems reality is gonna
hit you hard and it's gonna hurt your
self-esteem even more you thought this
was gonna be a fast fix it doesn't fix
the issue and your self-esteem is gonna
plummet more let me tell you this these
kinds of you know elective surgeries
they're not going to fix what you have
going on either side it is hard work and
it is unfair that some people have to
work way harder than others in order to
get there but it is your reality
specially if you are a guy this is also
a gang problem because if you are a girl
it doesn't really matter how you look is
there so many guests like me or in a
similar situation there's so many of us
unexplainable amount pure girl you can
find these guys here's the thing Woody's
misunderstandings that women don't want
guys like them because women base a lot
of their values on the kind of man they
choose and so if you are low quality
just the same way it's like you're a
girl right you're a girl had you but
what did she do she didn't want you to
flaunt you to anybody she said to walk
five meters behind me why because you
didn't fulfill her needs so even though
she was desperate and she needed one and
she had you she wasn't content because
women do not derive their pleasure that
way and so to think that just because
there's a lot of desperate men that
women and ugly women will be fulfilled
you're wrong about that and you're
misrepresenting what their experience is
like because I can assure you there are
a lot of ugly women who have it
extremely difficult ya know I think the
last party was really wrong about that
you have to prove you can prove your
skills you have to what do you have to
talk about well yeah different ways I
mean me being an ugly kid when I was a
kid it's been an ugly kid the thing that
got me out of there
comedy comedy made me more appealing
you're now gonna be attractive but
you're gonna be appealing and then you
being appealing is gonna change your
self-esteem there's a lot of theme that
revolves other promises he has right
here that revolves about self-esteem if
you change your self-esteem and stuff
like that it's gonna get a better view
but he's gonna argue that you're one of
those guys who looks normal or looks
pretty good fair can't understand his no
I cannot but it's still the fact that
it'll affect that everything that he's
trying to change was things around him
and not him he was not trying to better
himself and that's a fact what Lee
whether I'm pretty whether I'm normal it
doesn't matter if so it's a recurring
thing in what you said and you said it
yourself it showed in his speech of what
he said that hey as soon as you increase
your self-esteem it was better with the
other girl wasn't it because there was
probably some other [ __ ] that you were
not willing to deal with because you
were net less enabling her
so yeah that's not an argument to me no
I get it I was just playing is I
understand what you're saying yeah
absolutely but yeah I'm just it does get
better it can get better but it really
comes down to your approach to it and I
know for a lot of dudes who haven't
gotten there it seems hopeless and for a
lot of people who are in the similar
situations like this guy's just saying
that cuz he kind of lose good he's gotta
breath before I had this it was going
better for me I think once I got my
finances in order I worked hard like you
mentioned before I built a couple of
skill sets with dance it enabled me to
conversating to feel more comfortable in
myself and it displayed ambition it
displayed some value and so people
started to see that in me but it really
just came down to effort and it's hard
to tell someone that one they don't see
the light at the end of the tunnel to
tell them to keep digging but it is
there if Flavor Flav can make it a lot
of other people can make so just just
don't give up
all right and I know we laughed a little
bit we can crack some jokes but just
also be sure like we're not mocking you
and we're not trying to belittle you we
understand it's a real problem but I
would just say you don't have to give up
so that's pretty much all I got that's
it
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below do you guys agree with
the experience maybe you've had a
similar experience let's talk about what
it's like being ugly
[Music]
you